Bernardo writing in what's the best way
to stand out as a graphic designer for
graphic designer well you definitely
have the advantage of having a lot of
visuals on your side so I would
definitely start with you know adding
your portfolio or at least just some
examples of some of your best work to
your website you know definitely
showcase that and you know you can
definitely use content on your side to
just by blogging about some basics of
graphic design that can help you get um
discovered on search engines when people
are googling for you know really basic
things like what font should i use on my
website that's not going to be really
hideous like comic sans um no offense
anyone who likes common sense but it's
it's good to start with the basics there
and to you know really show that you're
a thought leader in your space and you
know a company that with visuals just
keep it basic for your your audience and
then when they're ready for taking their
graphics to the next level they can look
to you for a professional help yeah it's
a tough business because there's so many
graphic designers and a lot of people
think oh I'll just get my my nephew to
create something for me or my brother or
my high school friend it's been so
commoditized that it's hard to stand out
and I think the way to do it is is one
through the content through through
articles or videos or Twitter or
whatever your medium is if you're if
you're better on camera than you are in
writing then i would go youtube as my
content platform as opposed to writing
if you're a great writer go with the
blog or newsletter i'd also try to see
if if there's some kind of tribute
pieces i could make like what's so
unique about your style that's different
than everybody else that's the biggest
thing if i put out a job posting for a
graphic designer or get thousands of
people applying what is so different
about yours is going to make me want to
come to you as the default person right
what do you care about does that scream
through your art and i'd look at doing
some tribute pieces look at I don't know
if you're doing graphic design for you
don't logos if you're doing websites
brochures
have a fun time playing around like if
you love baseball I'm a big Toronto Blue
Jays fan we're going to the playoffs
this year finally redesigned their logo
right like put it in your own put your
own spin on it if you're a logo designer
right that could be content that you
release that something unique and
different that nobody else is doing and
people can get a flavor for for who you
are and the kind of work that you can do
I think it would challenge people and
make people think